trois jours trois scènes et 20 concerts
les chiffres clés pour profiter d'un
coin d'herbe et de musique
pour sa deuxième édition toujours
maintenu pour l'heure le festival eole
factory met en avant son patrimoine de
factures d'instruments ya aussi ce côté
a pas de barrière autoroutière entre les
styles de musique souvent on repère un
festival par rapport à son étiquette
jazz son étiquette musiques actuelles ou
son étiquette musique classique nous on
a envie de valoriser le tout de
valoriser les musiciens de valoriser la
pratique musicale et donc et même de
favoriser les ponts entre ces
différentes disciplines
grande amatrice de jazz la cantatrice
nathalie de ces relève le défi d'une
création et que le duke orchestra sont
aussi annoncés kassav et les têtes
raides une organisation possible grâce
au nombre de personnes autorisées
le festival ne vise pas la limite des
cinq mille personnes
les équipes planchent sur plusieurs
scénarii possibles pour l'instant on
parle beaucoup de du placement des
personnes des distanciation de recours à
certaines pratiques d'hygiène aussi de
nettoyage des différents éléments où on
parle aussi de distribution de jali
droit le gris pourquoi pas de de masques
etc
enfin tout ce qui est qui fait partie
maintenant finalement notre quotidien le
festival pourrait être une double fête
le 20 septembre mantes la jolie devrait
aussi être synonyme du départ de la
dernière étape du tour de france 2020
après avoir applaudi le pôle ton
pourquoi ne pas applaudir les artistes